foreign
the stats have come out a record 69
percent of the public at this time holds
a negative view about the economy so ask
yourself whether you're driving in your
car right now you're watching on YouTube
is that you do you have a negative view
of the economy right now the stats tell
us you probably do both now and in the
future lines because the headlines
exactly
um and only 24 here's we're just going
to go through this and tell you guys 24
are saying they don't feel like now is a
good time to invest in stocks all
they're saying now is a good time now is
a good time 76 say it's not a good time
yeah they're wrong they're wrong three
out of four people are saying don't
invest right now it's a bad time to
invest which is really just the opposite
because I'm like no when the when the
market is down that's when you want it
it's on sale sale the kind of sale I
want to fall for yeah and you know
there's just so many things going on uh
it says many people aren't cutting their
expenses and they're keeping their
lifestyle the same even though like I
said you you can throw a rock and hit
somebody who's gonna complain about
inflation you know you can throw a rock
and hit somebody who's going to complain
about mortgage prices complain about the
cost of a vehicle complain about their
wages complain about but at the same
time no one's doing anything to fix it
George well they're they're cutting back
on retirement this is wild historically
High inflation forced a quarter forced I
love that term they were absolutely
forced a quarter of Americans to slash
their retirement savings and a full 12
to quit saving entirely over the last
year
but on the other side we also have
record high credit card debt yep we're
seeing record numbers of helocs being
taken out and and record numbers of buy
now pay later when you say Rec we I I
want to hit this number George because
when you say record record numbers of
credit card debt I need you to
understand it's almost a to trillion
with a t that's a thousand billions and
a billion is a thousand Millions which
mean your brain just exploded with zeros
yeah that's just what happened right so
what this is telling us George is people
know there's a a problem they feel
there's a problem but they're going to
the wrong solution instead of saying hey
I'm going to stop borrowing credit card
debt or hey I'm not going to take out
any more you know any more of the equity
on my home instead they're doing things
like pulling back on their investing
using their savings you're you you feel
that there's a problem but you're using
the wrong solution in order to solve it
so let's try to help these people and
understand what you need to be doing
well there's a paradigm shift that has
to happen first because we can tell
people hey you should get out of debt
you should say from emergencies that's
all good and well but until you believe
that there is hope for the future until
you believe that the American economy
economy will recover like it always has
it always time and time again then
you're not going to do anything about it
when you listen to Hope Stealers and you
just become a victim right if inflation
is the villain then you're always going
to be a victim I love that that's so
true I need you need to say that again
George these folks need to hear that
again if inflation is your villain then
you will always be a victim because
guess what inflation ain't going
anywhere no it's been here since the
beginning of time it's just that there's
dinosaurs and inflation yep so it's not
going anywhere it's been higher than it
has been in the past but if you are real
your life is out of control because
inflation is up four percent higher than
it has been then you were already
screwed financially that's right that's
such a good point you know I I'm not
going to sit back here and act like
these these things that are taking place
aren't real yes like people are feeling
the pinch of inflation that's a real
thing people are feeling like they can't
spend their money as willy-nilly as they
once did because that that is the fact
like there is a pinch going on right now
but I think like you the point you made
George is true these things they hype
they happen in Cycles right there
there's always times when the market is
down it always rebounds back up but
you've got to understand that that's
just part of this thing and if you are
going to continually take those reasons
and say this is the reason that I can't
uh get out of debt this is the reason
that I've gotta you know use credit
cards to get by or this is the then
you're just those reasons are just
turning into excuses for you because at
some point you've got to make that
transition and go okay what can I
personally do because I I'm the type of
person whatever it is that you're
whining and in complaining about there's
probably something that you can do
personally to change it for the better
instead of waiting for some external
factor to come in whether it be the
government or whether it be for your job
to give you a raise because they may not
give you a raise you're telling me the
boss and the government aren't going to
change my life come on Jade here's the
thing the people who are complaining
these are the same people who fall into
these stats Americans spent 20.7 percent
more at restaurants than they spent on
groceries in 2022. now there it is wait
a second hold on so we're all struggling
and so we're gonna go eat out because
that's the solution well George to our
spending problem you know it's cheaper
to eat I gotta say this in a voice
better to eat in a restaurant my time is
worth
more than that I
making food my time is more valuable
than that they just put the YouTube
sound effect on that is every YouTube
commenter every tick tocker out there
and then Jade on travel right Revenge
travels back Delta reported record
Advanced bookings for summer travel
despite industry-wide inflation and
fares so air travel is the most
expensive it's been in a long time and
we're all out there going we're going to
book this thing six months out on the
credit card because we're going to get
the points we're going to use the points
we're going to hack the system bro the
system is hacking you it's hacking
you're the hack
yeah it's insane this is like an
intellectual inconsistency because on
this side you're you're saying oh it's a
problem this is not fair but then over
there it's like yeah but it must not be
that much of a problem because I'm still
going to restaurants I'm still going on
a trip to Hawaii and I'm still gonna
take out a car note for 717 because
that's the price of the average car note
right now and then let's talk about the
economy Jade because this is the true
fear but I have some perspective to
share that I think will make everyone
feel better yeah these are real numbers
in the last 40 years the S P 500 which
is the index that is used to really
track the stock market in the U.S in the
last 40 years the S P 500 was up 32 of
those 40 years that's right and get this
22 of those years there was a return
greater than 12 percent wow everyone out
there you mean you're making 12 well
dude you're looking at your 401k in the
last year or two have some perspective
the S P 500 was up over 12 percent for
22 out of the last 40 years I'm not
betting against the American economy and
I don't think you should either and when
you look at it the years that it was
down the next year it's rebounded right
back up so when it's down you're buying
on sale when it's up you are making some
sweet coin and that's how you build
wealth you just leave it don't touch it
don't pull it out because you're scared
because you saw a headline and
especially don't turn to buy now pay
later and he locks as some kind of
Solution please all your problems please
please I I feel like we need to give
these people what the true solution is
because George you and I know it you
know like I said you guys feel that
there's a problem and you're right there
is a problem but the solution is not
borrowing more money you cannot borrow
your way out of debt you cannot borrow
your way out of financial strain you've
got to actually draw a line in the sand
you've got to stop borrowing money